الينا من عمان اللواء فايز دويري الخبير
العسكري
والاستراتيجيه سيد اللواء هناك تضارب
للانباء بخصوص حقيقه ما يجري في بخمه
القوات المواليه لروسيا تتحدث عن تطويق
المدينه القوات الاوكرانيه في ذلك وحديث
عن هجمات من ثلاثه محاور كيف يمكن فهم
حقيقه الوضع في
يعني منذ بدايه الحرب هناك تضخيم من جانب
وتقليل من الجانب الاخر
وشاهدناه في ماريوبول في سيفرو دينسك في
غيرها من المناطق ولكن تتضح الامور بعد
اسبوعين الى ثلاث اسابيع من
حتى يتم تجسير الهوا ما بين الموقفين
واقرب شيء الحديث عن سوليدار سوليدار
تقريبا
اخذت من عشره ايام الى اسبوعين حتى تم
الاعتراف الكامل بسقوطها من قبل الجانب
الاوكراني اذا كان هناك تعظيم للمنجزات من
الجانب الروسي وتقليل لحجم الانجازات
وبالتالي كانت الضحيه دائما هي الحقيقه
الان
يعني حتى قبل الحديث عن باق مدعين يشير
الى نقطه الان اذا القينا نظره على مسرح
العمليات في الشرق الاوكراني والجنوب
الاوكراني
المتابع سيجد ان الجيش الروسي بدا يستلم
زمام المباداه في المستوى التكتيكي
وتقريبا في المستوى العملياتي اصبح هو
المهاجم بصوره اكبر هو الذي يحقق انجازات
وان كانت متواضعه ولكنها تراكميه تفضي الى
انجازات رئيسيه اعود الى نقطه او منطقه
باخبط باخموت بالنسبه للخط الدفاعي الذي
اشار اليه المراسل للصحفي مراسل الجزيره
هي بيضه القبان سقوط بها موت يعني تداعيات
قد تكون كبيره ويصعب احتوائها من قبل
الجيش الاوكراني على الاقل في اقليم
دونيسك لماذا اشار الى الطرق التي تصل الى
سلفيا ديسك او الى الجنوب الغربي والان
اشار الى امكانيه الحركه عبر الضواحي لكن
قال
هل القوات الموجود قادره على الصمود لفتره
طويله تقارب الفتره التي سمادت لا اعتقد
ذلك لماذا لانه هناك تنوع في اداره
المعركه من قبل القوات المهاجمه القوات
الروسيه تهاجم بطريقه معينه قوات فيجنر
تقاتل بطريقه مختلفه اكثر مهنيه اكثر
احترافا اكثر خطوره لماذا لانها تحاول ان
تسيطر على الاراضي الحاكم والاراضي
المسيطره تحاول قطع طرق الامداد اذا ما
قطعت طرق الامداد تصبح القوات المحاصره
واحده
وبالتالي لان التاريخ العسكري علم يقول ان
هناك يعني ما مدى خطوره هذه التداعيات وهل
تبدا ربما بسيطره على كرامات
يا سيدي يعني التداعيات وانت اشرت الى قلب
الحقيقه اذا ما سقطت باخموت ماذا يعني ذلك
يعني ان الطريق اصبحت الى سلافيا مسك
مفتوحه الطريق الى كرامات رسك مفتوحه
السيطره على كلا المدينه يعني ايزيوم
اصبحت اييييي قريبه جدا والتي دفع ثمن
باهظا للسيطره عليها اذا دعني اقول ان
سقوط باخ موت بصوره كامله قد يقضي اقول قد
يفضي الى استعاده السيطره على ما فقد فكره
موتورز وهذا يعيدني الى النقطه التي كنت
تتحدث بها القوات المحاصره تصبح واحده
والقوات وتصبح القوات الاوكراني في موقف
صعب لهذا السبب القوات المحاصره يجب ان
يتم امدادها بقوات وليس فقط اسلحه يجب ان
يتم امدادها بقوات من مختلف الصنوف حتى
تبقي طرق الامداد مفتوحه وتقدم تعزيزات
اضافيه تمكنها من الصمود ريس ما يتم
استعاده التوازن في منطقه العمليات دون
ذلك
عاجلا ام اجلا اذا استمرت الوتيره على هذا
على هذا الواقع والحال ستسقط باك
متلامحاله ولكن اذا ما تم تعزيز القوات
الموجوده بها بقوات قادمه من مناطق
الاسلام
توريسك وما خلف ذلك ستكون هناك قصه اخرى
الغربيه ستساهم في ذلك حديث الان عن حزمه
مساعدات جديده لكيف تفوق مليارين دولار
وتتضمن صواريخ بعيده المدى كذلك
اذا وصلت
الصواريخ الجديده جي ال اس دي بي هذه
مداها 150 كيلومتر كانت
هيمارس 80 كم 79 الى 80 كم هذه القذائف
اللي تسمى القذائف الدقيقه الدقيقه القطر
ااه لها مواصفات معينه تطلق من الارض تعمل
بالاقمار الصناعيه تعطي عمق ل 150 كيلو
متر اذا ما وصلت باعداد كافيه وتم
استخدامها بصوره فاعله داعينا نتحدث الان
ان في عمق المنطقه العمليات وبالتجاه
روسيا والاقاليم التي تم ضمها يمكن تدمير
كافه نقاط التكديس والمستودعات والحاق
الضرر بالقوافل وهنا سيكون تاثيرها يوازي
او يفوق تاثير همم منظومات هيمارس التي
استخدمت همم في في فتره معارك خارجه
واسيوم وغيرها شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فايزه
الدويري العسكري والاستراتيجي حدثنا من
عمان